I'm at Space Camp in Huntsville Alabama
and this is the multi-axis trainer or ma
T otherwise known as that spinny thing
that astronauts get strapped into this
is an icon of space exploration and
space training and it looks really fun
or really terrifying depending on how
close you are to it but what does it
actually do know when you come to Space
Camp you typically ride the m84 no
longer than forty-five seconds the m80
spins on three different axes and three
different rings the outer ring is locked
the center ring is powered by a motor
and then the inner ring is free spinning
and then inside that is a chair that is
also spinning on a different axis while
you're riding the m80 you don't spin in
more than one direction twice in a row
so you don't get dizzy or nauseous but
you do get disoriented it's a very
important difference that they feel as
your stomach stays in the center of
rotation you're gonna get a lot of blood
and momentum feeling in your head and
your feet most people love the feeling
of the multi-axis trainer they love the
feeling of being disoriented without
being dizzy which is a really rare
experience for most roller coasters or
simulators like this it's based off of
something called the Mastiff which was
used during the Mercury program the
Mastiff was actually a series of cages
around a central chair the m80 is a
series of rings during the 1960s
astronauts in the mercury and Gemini
programs would need to train on
something like the Mastiff because of
the shape of their vehicle it's a
capsule and it would spin very
erratically if something were going
wrong unlike the shuttle astronauts
where they were in something more plane
shaped and so when something is going
wrong in a plane it doesn't act the same
so the mercury astronauts weren't just
strapped into this thing's Big Brother
to disorient them it was training if
something Oh like this is happening in
space then your mission has gone
disastrously wrong in training they will
be spun up to anything up to 30
revolutions a minute much faster than
this with much higher g-forces and then
the trainer would hand the controls over
to them the astronauts chair would Oh
have controls on it connected to
nitrogen gas thrusters they would have
to work out which way they were spinning
in three dimensions in real time and
then they would have to figure out how
to make it stop for me it's a little bit
easier
could we yeah can we make this stop
please the MIT was never used to
actually train astronauts we only use it
as a simulator here at Space Camp I've
actually written the MIT as well we had
to do it for training I like to say that
most people don't get dizzy because
there are some people who do I'm one of
them
I completely forgot to do the outro can
we can we go again please oh there we go
thank you very much to all the team at
Space Camp you can find out more about
them at the links on screen or in the
description yeah I'm done I'm very much
done